one train is like i went the [ __ ] off
it's like it should be in a museum to me
i'm gonna tell you just being a funny
story about this [ __ ] the reason why i
was like i don't give a [ __ ] i'm gonna
do a i'm gonna do a 32 i'm gonna just
keep going we do the uh bt award cipher
bt tell us write 12 bars to this
instrumental
cool we get to the site for everybody
kicking [ __ ] 48s and 64s and [ __ ] my
versus a 12. i'm like i'll never again
get a [ __ ] instrumental and not
just go crazy so once rocky sent me to
me and i love the way he did it because
it was like nobody heard nobody's verse
so he got an instrumental bro any idea
who's going to be i don't know what the
[ __ ] going to be on the song
yeah i'm like i'm so young
wow i'm gonna say i'm gonna go [ __ ]
crazy and the bb king line r.i.p the the
legend because who it was yourself wolf
joey badass
uh danny brown yeah
uh
[Music]
kendrick was on it kendrick was on it
[ __ ] that was that was a moment that's
crazy that was the moment yeah
it's it's so that was bold for that one
that was that was dope